this episode is made possible by shaker
and spoon sign up using the link below
and save $20 on your subscription
it's not often channels like mine get to
do a video on alcohol so we're going to
have a bit of fun this episode I went
out and found all the drinks on this
list and over the course of the video
I'll be making and testing and drink
containing each of them wish me luck
humanity has a long and storied history
of making and consuming fermented
beverages from the fairly tame to the
downright diabolical as far back as nine
thousand years ago we clever humans were
inventing ways to intoxicate ourselves
and throw killer Neolithic parties and
that trend has continued to this day
suggesting that humanity's favorite
pastime may not be baseball or football
but rather getting totally smashed and
regretting it the next day while many
adults enjoy a drink or two after a long
day or over the weekend not all
alcoholic beverages are created equal
and in some cases a drink or two might
be all it takes to put you off the stuff
for good so without further ado let's
look at some of the most notorious
drinks you can buy we'll start with one
particular spirit that developed such a
bad reputation that it was banned in
many countries for several decades
this is absinthe the legendary Green
Fairy absinthe is a highly alcoholic
spirit derived from botanicals including
the leaves and flowers of Artemisia
absinthium or grand wormwood originally
developed in Switzerland in the late
18th century
absinthe became associated with bohemian
or non traditional culture which earned
it a spot on many governmental naughty
lists revolutionaries like Hemingway
Picasso van Gogh and Oscar Wilde were
all known absinthe drinkers but it
wasn't just the clientele that gave
absent the bad rap the potent drink also
contains a chemical compound called
thujone which led to the drinks
classification as an addictive
psychoactive drug or hallucinogen
whether or not these fears were based in
reality is not entirely certain but
absinthe was banned in the United States
in 1915 regardless as well as in much of
Europe including France the Netherlands
Belgium Switzerland and austria-hungary
in more recent years studies have shown
that absent psychoactive properties are
greatly exaggerated and the Green Fairy
is back in production in over a dozen
countries and back on the shelves of
stores around the world so now if you
want to you can try the legendary spirit
for yourself just be warned that while
it might not be hallucinogenic it's
still a pretty potent alcohol usually
between 45 and 74 percent ABV next up we
have this filthy concoction courtesy of
the good old USA
Four Loko was released in the US market
in 2005 and is currently available in 49
states and in 21 countries around the
world the four loko you can buy today is
a much tamer beast than the original
which was banned in several states after
legal ethical and health concerns were
raised regarding the marketing practices
and contents of the beverage alcohol
alone can be dangerous but when you
throw caffeine into the mix things can
get very bad very quickly the original
recipe called for the equivalent of four
standard drinks worth of alcohol five
cups of coffees worth of caffeine as
well as taurine and gharana popular
ingredients in energy drinks so when you
drank four loko in 2005 you were playing
Russian roulette by combining large
quantities of uppers caffeine and
downers alcohol you could keep drinking
the stuff without feeling the onset of
the effects of alcohol so you'd keep
drinking more the fun part was guessing
whether you'd end up in an ambulance
from alcohol poisoning or a heart attack
luckily after the ban the company
changed the recipe and removed all
caffeine taurine and guarana and is no
longer marketed as an energy drink now
it's just a really inexpensive and
unpleasant way to consume a lot of
alcohol next up we have the Internet's
favorite challenge shot
the brutal grain alcohol known as
Everclear this american-made bottle of
liquid misery is available in two
strengths 151 and 190 proof or 75.5 and
95 percent alcohol by volume that's a
lot of alcohol so much that the sale of
the 190 proof is prohibited in some
states luckily I live in the lawless
wasteland that is Texas so what you're
seeing here is the big-boy version there
comes a point when your alcohol is just
too strong to drink for example some
alternative uses for Everclear include
the fact that it's often recommended as
a camping stove fuel substitute and that
carpenters often use it with shellac to
produce high-grade wood sealants on the
plus-side Everclear has a very neutral
flavor profile so if you want a really
strong drink that will play nicely with
your favorite mixers this would actually
mix pretty well just don't overdo it the
last drink on our list is about as
American as it gets
though originally brought over by
scots-irish immigrants when you hear the
word moonshine you probably think of a
bunch of Appalachian hillbillies hiding
from law enforcement out in the woods
and that's pretty much the gist of it in
the early 1900s moonshine provided a
huge boost in revenue for Appalachian
farmers since the limited roads made
difficult to transport corn crops they
quickly realized that a horse could
carry ten times the value of corn by
first converting it into whiskey while
the term moonshine originally referred
to illegally produced liquor it's since
been reclaimed by producers of legal
products in an effort to market them as
a similar drinking experience to the
original white lightning the problem
with early moonshine is that there was
no way to regulate it
if farmer Joe said his batch would get
you drunk you just have to take his word
for it and roll the dice you never knew
what was in the drink and impurities in
the still often caused health problems
including blindness and lead poisoning
proper moonshine finally became legal in
the United States in 2010 and is defined
as a clear on aged whiskey it's sale is
still heavily regulated by the ATF but
the stuff you buy at your local liquor
store is pretty much guaranteed not to
kill you or make you go blind at least
in reasonable quantities so if you're in
the mood for a drink once considered so
dangerous it had to be banned you've got
your short list just remember don't
drink if you're underage and for those
of you who do try these concoctions be
safe and drink responsibly and if you'd
rather play it safe and try some much
tastier drinks I highly recommend you
check out shaker and spoon shaker and
spoon is a monthly cocktail subscription
box that delivers a craft cocktail
experience right to your home every
month you'll get three brand-new
original recipes created by world-class
bartenders as well as enough ingredients
for 12 cocktails four from each recipe
each monthly box revolves around one
type of liqueur so you only need to add
the one bottle for all three recipes
don't worry if you're not a drink mixing
expert shaker and spoon provides easy to
follow instructions and how-to videos to
make your own beautiful complex
cocktails I'm certainly no professional
when it comes to mixing drinks but it's
a lot of fun to open the monthly box and
watch an awesome cocktail come together
as a little bonus for fans of second
thought anyone who signs up using the
link below will save $20 on their
subscription visit shaker and spoon comm
slash second thought to save on your
subscription and start making awesome
craft cocktails today if you enjoyed
this video make sure to subscribe and
click the little bell next to my channel
name to join the notification squad you
can watch my previous videos by clicking
here or watch my most popular videos by
clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you in the next video
you